cementec généralement un corsage que vous faites -
je suis certain demain moi Mario
[ __ ] avec le Nigeria le mien déjà
Daisuke a pleuré toute la nuit devant toi à
moitié foutu
Suzanne est maintenant devenue l'épicentre d'
une collision entre l'Amérique et la Chine,
il est facile de choisir  les ressources naturelles
et les congés, nous ne voulons pas voir un nouveau
colonialisme en Afrique, mais là,
vous savez que l'extraction de l'énergie est ce que Dieu
veut, vous pouvez tout ce que j'ai assisté de
cette façon, mais vous savez quelle est la première
exigence pour que Dieu réponde d'abord à vos
prières  vous devez lui permettre de changer votre
cœur nous avons choisi une pièce
nous vous apportons au propre comme au figuré
la lumière